so people have asked for a house tour
but our house is too big to fit all the
rooms so
i'm just gonna fit all the rooms that i
can in a 60 second video
so this is our great room it's what you
see when you come into the house
if we move this way this is the dining
room this is where me and my nine
siblings will have dinner
i like it because i've never actually
seen a table that's this big
in my life if we keep moving this way
this is our kitchen
there's a mini table there for the kids
and then there's a
smaller table for when not all of the
siblings are in town over there
is the great room that's kind of just a
hangout area my mom's desk area
i've given a kitchen tour on this
channel before but this is just a rough
overview obviously i'm trying to keep
this as quick as possible
over here is our laundry room a lot of
people have compared it to a laundry mat
this is where we put our coats and stuff
um over here is
all the laundry stuff my mom uses i'm
not even gonna lie
i don't really do laundry